M I think you had something else you
wanted to deal with too right we were
talking before the show went
live um oh well that was more I'm I'm G
to cover that on on my thing but as far
as like the 401K stuff goes yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you want to talk about no
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna do talking
about the dinks too right yeah yeah I
mean look like you guys can go back and
watch it it's on it's on the channel I
mean
but what's
so there's it's this phenomenon it pops
up every like six months where you've
got these couples that are on Tik Tok or
Instagram or whatever talking about the
dink lifestyle which is dual income no
kids um I think you posted the video on
your Twitter timeline let me just pull
it up while you're talking yeah there's
one yeah yeah yeah and then I think I
have it still
somewhere or if you want to pull that up
yeah it's posted yeah I'll dig it up
while you're talking I'll put up on the
screen um and these this particular one
went viral I think this did like 4
million hits in a couple of days but you
know it's this not actually bad looking
chick and this very fat frumpy looking
husband talking about all the things
they're able to do and all the things
they're able to buy just because they
don't have kids and so they they frame
it as we're not wasting money on a CH on
a child so we can spend money on
ourselves and buy things like lattes
yeah this is the video all right so it's
29 seconds we can just play it real
quick uh hang on do I have audio
selected give me a second here
here H I got to hit a button here to
select audio uh share audio tab yeah
okay you guys should be able to hear
this on having kids sorry we're gonna
get asked daily when we plan on having
kids we're dinks of course we're gonna
go out to eat every night after work
we're dinks we don't have to ask our how
did a fat dork get a cutie like this
right or we want to go
out look at this
guy
we're gonna go to Costco and buy all the
snacks and bulk that we want we're gonna
get all the snacks and bulk all the
snacks and we're g to eat them look at
my if you distill this distill this
message down it's like give up having
children and consume instead who do you
think pushing this message who is
pushing this message it's obviously cons
you know it's consumer companies as well
I'm not a conspiracy theorist they're
like telling us they can go out and buy
stuff you don't have to go and buy stuff
to be happy go for a walk in the park
you know we have osble income to spend
on whatever we would like and don't have
to spend on a kid we're dings I'm going
to go to Every football game and play 18
holes whenever I want we're dinks we're
gonna get asked to every single family
event what we're doing with our life
we're dinks we're g so dink the acronym
is not new by the way I'm actually
surprised that they got this trending as
like a new acronym because it's been
around for decades um they started
talking about this [__] when I was in
school you know about about people not
having kids and going the double income
route so this is a this is an old notion
so them you know rehashing this is
something new is kind of interesting but
you know hashtag dink noids couple fyp
the dink lifestyle that's think you know
like what the issue is that I see with
this like nobody's debating their their
their choices but they're virtual
signaling like we're better than you
guys because we're doing this like what
you're deciding not have kids yeah
people try to their own ego Investments
and that's what they're basically doing
yeah that's major achievement deciding
to not have kids like are you that weak
well people that are happy with their
choices don't have to are not making
videos like this there's nothing sadder
than the people that are making videos
shouting about how happy they are
they're the most more unhappy people
those those who shout the loudest of the
most to hide yeah I'm I'm going to take
an alternative point on this and I don't
think that it's dink by choice I think
it's dink forced on them because he has
low te and low sperm count and they
can't have
kids when you're a fat dork like that I
can tell you right now your tea levels
are in the toilet your sperm count is
low there's lots of people right now in
their 20s and 30s that cannot have kids
because they've got no sperm motility
because those are lifestyle choices and
when somebody's fat like that in their
20s I can tell they're inflamed I can
tell they're absolutely out of shape I
can tell they're endocrine panels upside
down it's a
disaster in his in his case dink stands
for diabetic incel no
kids you know like something else that
just popped into my mind right now is
like their major um argument is that
they have more time and that they have
more disposable income like why don't
you make more
money look this this argument for kids
okay I I I I I don't want to sound like
someone that's perpetuating slavery but
the amount of stuff I get my kids to do
around the house now is great cuz
they're team my son starts stacking logs
bringing it in my daughter helps with me
with cooking and cleaning and stuff like
that and I think you guys like these
people around about enjoying things you
you guys saw the picture that I posted
during the week when I took my daughter
to crumble cookies and she spent the
rest of the day laughing her butt off
over that joke what I pulled off when I
put the you go into crumble cookies and
you have to enter a name on the screen
for pickup and I didn't know there was a
big notice
board and I put I put in the name
butthole and my 14-year-old daughter had
to go up and it came up on the screen
and the lady outside looked in and she
ran out of the place laughing giggling
the whole day and then and then me and
her will get up early on the weekends
we'll sneak into my son's bedroom we'll
fart and we'll close the door and we'll
run out okay it's you know I dink all
you want but you're not going to get
that out of life if you're a dink I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clip's from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out